I think the world is watching they think
this is a very exciting moment is
America going to renew itself and you
know the fact that Obama's election
means so much symbolically to people all
over the world I think that there is a
chance you know that he will raise
expectations elsewhere you know we call
it the power of a good example when you
see something like you see a
breakthrough like this in a country that
as conservative as the United States and
then you look at your own country and
you say well why can't I have some of
that here and likewise the people are
looking at the tools that are being used
like the social networking tools that
you know obama put to very good use in
his campaign and there you know the
possibilities are opening up right and
it doesn't take that many people all
having a similar idea at the same time
now to coalesce in some new ways so i
expect we will begin to see you know
like a ripple effect in other parts of
the world absolutely